so so let's talk about that so let's
talk about
uh working from home or working from an
office so
to me i've recruited a lot of people in
my career
uh i've recruited a lot of people that
didn't fit my culture
over my career i've recruited people
that do well under pressure
i've recruited people that don't do well
under pressure i've recruited people
that
do well working with their wives i've
recruited people that don't do well
working with their
wives right i've recruited people that
um
you know are hard working hard
charging constantly going but but the
one thing i will tell you is
i've seen that people that are solo
people there are people that are team
people
you got the solo you got the team it's
like sports
you got kids that want to play tennis
you got kids that like playing golf
yeah you got kids that like playing like
swimming why because
it's wrestling it's operating it's me i
control my failure and success and they
like it 100
yeah it's like hey i want to be an
attorney okay
i want to be an accountant i want to be
a sales person
i want to be a i person surgeon i want
to be this right
and then there's those that are team now
here's what typically happens to teen
people team people have been team people
for their entire lives
okay these are people that want to be
around others these are people that
enjoy
company these are people that don't want
to go to the movies by themselves
they're going to call and say what are
you doing let's go to watch them
hey these are people that hey you let's
go play basketball together you know
the guy that always knew how to put
let's go to the club five of you roll up
this one guy that i don't want to go
it's like the guy that would concert bro
get out of your bed
10 o'clock let's go oh man i'm tired bro
you're 20 years old you've got plenty of
video games now
everybody has that one friend right that
wants to be the team guy
you know what typically happens with
solo people here's what happens with
solo people
solo people some early some later
solo people eventually get to a point in
their lives where they have to make a
decision
and here's what solo people have to make
a decision they have to make a decision
whether
i want to do it all by myself because
i'm
chapped being solo yeah solo's got a cap
yep because you can't take over the
world by yourself your cap
team people are not limited solo people
eventually when they get to that point
and make a decision
to go work on a team they need a team
around them
they tend to take their lives and their
game to the next level what's my point
i'm making to you here
working from home is solo working from
home is not necessarily a team thing
working from an office environment
together it's a whole team situation
that you have there
you know you you kind of get a chance to
sit down and even right here there's a
certain dynamic going on here yeah
i had a chance to meet his family last
night i wouldn't have made it
luisa's who brought the whole family
we're working over here you know uh sam
and i had him
he took care of me a couple of times i
said mario gotta i like the way this guy
takes care of us he's class he's
like a concierge service at the highest
level right
you sit there i've had how many times
have i spoken to your mom kai how many
times have your mom and i have
conversations together
i talked to his mom and i got i know it
sounds weird but i'm telling him his
mom's happily married and i'm happy
but i've talked to kai's mom multiple
times and you said you're like hey
family
what's up but if it's not here and
you're walking past the desk there isn't
that opportunity to say
hey how you doing because it's at home
so that deep
additional connection of layers doesn't
happen
if it's not face to face in a group but
doesn't it always just come back to
culture you've created enough it works
culture
yeah it works it's a culture but nobody
emotionally gets attached to something
that they work from home
yeah you can't get attached to something
that could work from home emotionally
yeah
and typically when people want to run
through a wall for a company or a
message or an organization
it's got to be in a group environment so
that's the thing when it comes down to
this part
you